vite quel est le truc le plus fou voilà
que vous aimeriez faire un truc de ouf
castaldi serait quoi d'arrêter de prêter
ses traits du nord me refaire tout tout
le visage
non il ya une raison ma femme est folle
de keanu reeves nom me refaire tout le
visage pour ressembler keanu reeves
était déjà les yeux des petits la
liseuse petit ouais mais c'est vrai que
ça des petits jouent qu'avec elle est
folle de combat alors là je voulais que
s'ils passent dans la rue c'est bon je
divorce
ouais ouais bah oui alors été plus qui
n'eut de brive
[Rires]
ah ouais mais tu le ferais pour ta femme
c'est une belle preuve d'amour avec ce
franchement marois qu'est ce que tu
aimerais faire de moustoir jamais fait
un truc que je kifferais mais que basso
en parachute c'est vrai vraiment ce qui
ferait une fois je suis j h allée
jusqu'à demander à ta base et j'ai perdu
mes clientes serré benhaim tatouage de
boulettes
non au contraire j'aimerais bien mais
j'ai la trouille et après j'ai encore
une comprenait un problème sur votre
micro apparemment vous a coupé le micro
vous savez qu à quatre jours de la fin
des émissions ce créneau vinci
généralement celui qui a le micro coupé
le lundi 4 jours avant la fin des
émissions
je pense que valérie qu'est ce que vous
faites à la rentrée j'aimerais bien
faire un tatouage on peut faire entrer
quelqu'un du son bar en croûte mosseri
arnaud tsamère voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
si ça vous dira hyper-v rétro sexy away
sur vous haoues henry youtube c'est quoi
tu ferais une panthère a fait une
boulette avec de merguez d'un couscous
royal sont enfin couscous royal enfin kg
en effet là je suis encore là vous
trouvez qu'il était pas moi je pense que
je suis pas le seul à avoir souvent
placé jamais appris qu'une journée dans
votre tête c'est une journée au plus
près la création parce que franchement
[Applaudissements]
quelques centaines de fois à vos côtés
pour réaliser qu'à peu près de 10% de
tout ce qui vous passe par la tête et
acheva tout ce que vous réalisez ça
réussit donc si j'étais là dans ma tête
je vous ai ramassé écrit qu'est ce qui
vous prend vite fait quelques miettes je
peux je pense que je pourrais être un
jour milliardaire oui c'est vrai il est
suspect j'adore vous êtes super merci à
tous tout vous touchez et d'or se classe
tout ce que vous touchez se réalise a
mis à bercy que je vais rater de roduit
l'apa signe encore rien à coiffure moi
je rêverais d'être 24 heures vraiment
une seule journée
un homme ah oui mais être vraiment envie
sortir de chez moi vous pour avoir mes
voisins mes collègues l'armée en sommes
mais en homme d'état
oui mais pour voir un peu le regard que
porterait un homme que les gens envers
les hommes et des femmes sur moi à moi
24 mois c'est au met en garde je suis
d'accord mais c'est pas pour ça que tout
est d'avoir ce que c'est que de faire
l'amour quelle sensation vous ressentez
et qu'elle se paumer
[Rires]
les gens par exemple vous regarde dans
la rue en général et houria beauce
incroyable vos fesses et on regarde mais
messin pessah déjà regardons ça je suis
un bon plutôt ce qui se passe gardez vos
cuisses vous avez des très belles
cuisses c'est vrai qu'il ya des cuisses
se balader vous avez déjà réussi mais
bon moi j'aurais aimé être là rosso le
temps d'un concert un bercy un zénith où
sont les mêmes cheveux latinas comme ça
alors on l'a on l adore mais mon rêve
s'arrête c'est pourquoi pas bien mais
c'est ma régénération larusso
attaqueront bab un voile adore aussi
mais je suis sûr de moi oui adoré ouais
vous savez comment ça va votre fièvre va
mal c'est un match chez les malades ans
je voulais vous dire elle vient mais je
peux vous dire elle verse trouve non pas
de gastrovaud ça y est la gastro la
clippers ça y est la plus de gastro
luigi me mohamed qui est médecin ou plus
vous c'est quoi votre rêve ce serait de
pouvoir allaiter pendant 24 heures alité
enfin martin et par là les parents un
sport vraiment vraiment mais vraiment je
suis fasciné par l'allaitement pas dans
un sens bizarre comme jean-michel mais
dans le sens où mais c'est vrai malgré
les progrès de la médecine on est
incapable de reproduire le lait maternel
c'est un enfant qui né prématuré ne peut
pas recevoir de lait artificiel et on
donne le lait maternel donc quand la
femme ne peut pas donner c'est un lait
de diriger du lactarium et donc on se
rend compte que c'est que chose
extraordinaire et souvent on sous estime
pas donc vraiment moi ça me fascine et
j'aimerais avoir cette possible aquarium
lactariums le lactarium était dans le
lactarium c'est un endroit où les femmes
peuvent faire des pays de l'est pour
donner justement aux enfants prématurés
qui ne peuvent pas recevoir de lait
artificiel lactariums le lactarium
exactement ça pas là bas
[Rires]
on n'est pas le nom d'un parc
d'attractions genre avec des bouteilles
de lait by their de rêver de données de
rêver de la couche est de donner la vie
non mais vraiment ça va avec
à chacun son truc en alors quand vous
aimeriez à coucher ou non mais qui fait
acquis d'affaires l'allaitement je peux
faire drainer la vie carrément la salle
de taxi bouffe c'est beau c'est vrai
qu'elle est et puis ce tome i puis du
rachat leur duvet les mecs là ça y est
la ronde et méchante et la rigueur oui
bonsoir vous avez fait d'allaiter pas
dormi de plus combien d'années
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m étais tu as fait ce week end sur
l'année de 1 quand j'ai fait un camp
pour le climat gusty nice était romain
j'ai senti qu'elle avait pharma donc ma
chérie sur la tête de ma mère kabli
tongs et fera pas beaucoup dormi non
mais c'est ouf frère at on nommait mois
mais en fait et transparentes
je t'adore bloquant une tv dans la paume
non mais sur un bien on voit qu'elle a
pas beaucoup dans l'ue mais ge qui n'a
non sans guide staff et l'ama et ben on
a fait d'aider on a sur quoi des
épreuves surtout sur le co2 sur la
biodiversité sur les vaches sur le web
carium la mention non mais moi aussi
j'aimerais savoir ce que ça fait là
laitiers l'accord et c'était que ce
serait quoi vous merci
si vous deviez faire la toilette et vous
deviez faire un truc à moi dans un nid
d'aigle dans un nid d'aigle
[Applaudissements]
ramos excellent mais surtout question à
[ __ ] dans un nid d'aigle trois ténors
de la droite et du siisneq tu crois quoi
dans un nid d'aigle quoi s'attendre à
gaza règle déjà ce que j'accusais d'or
tu veux pourquoi dans un de mes disques
j'adore les aigles ouais les voir planer
les voir rentrer au niveau voire les
serres en avant mais tu vas leur dire tu
parlais glop jeu par le corbeau vas-y
palois ne vous jure que ses voisines
palois et quand je fais ça les corbeaux
alors est-ce qu'on pouvait sortir il ya
des corbeaux dans la région est sorti
dans paris je suis battu c'est aller sur
wave est gardée comme moi sincèrement ça
roule mal à l'aise mais tous là écoute
je souhaite si cholet ce combo sa volt
hyper daldry pas la saveur lieberman
henri parriat rocade en 1h12 du ckpa de
corbeau est au refus ferme à cette heure
ci sont pas là ils sont là le matin
c'est pour toi sorciers des courbes ou
la wii ils sont là il s'endort verser
20,6 au bar à chicha
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez fais de toi
de quoi mais ça aurait aidé ou tu sais
d'où tu parles quand bouton même parce
que je vous jure qu'on songe maintenant
je m'entraîne à faire plusieurs chants
d'oiseaux les voies d'oiseaux et les
corbeaux ya quinze jours on peut pas te
suivre matin quand même si donc le matin
ça veut dire toi t'es complètement sa
vie alors tu te réveilles à 4 heures du
matin parce qu'elle parte izel à 4
heures du matin et genre t'es comme apte
et pendant une heure lié à tony j'ai
rendez vous avec des corbeaux cependant
d'une tortue pas le corbeau vas-y
trophée et l'accueil et la famine sont
tous allaient venir abonder
montceau-les-mines de quoi bien ça
patois local elle parle patois incombe
aux lois ouais c'est ça ne parle que les
corbeaux de montceau-les-mines sentiment
sur les mines patois un mot de korbous
bon bernard montiel le truc le plus
dingue vous allez me ce serait tout
plaquer changer de vie totalement vas-y
que le haut en bas
[Applaudissements]
mais je pense aux nombreux tête dans un
estuaire ses choix c'est pas non plus
des bornes perso s'il changeait de vivre
non mais attends thatta une ville
magnifique arrête oui j'en rigolais ses
18 heures au point soleil et core i7
vivre autre chose les formations ont en
effet d'autres rencontres en fait
j'aimerais aller en afrique parce que je
vois qu'il ya tout un tas de méthodes
magnifique par exemple pour aider les
villages ses berges une occasion d'y
aller souvent apporter l'électricité
c'est facile avec le soleil à des
méthodes maintenant qu'on peut alimenter
des villages en haut il ya des femmes
ils font des kilomètres dans des
associés moi tu savais pas bernard messi
suis déjà dans des associations mais la
joie est sur le terrain des foyers
j'aimerais y aller mais pourquoi tu le
fais pas mais j'ai déjà parraine
l'association justement je veux y aller
mais il faut lever notre pourquoi qu'il
va pas mais je vais le faire l'année
prochaine dans un an à l'horloge tourne
on peut revenir tu fais des alertes
intense et non dans un entendez un an
j'ai posé moins de questions qu'il
fallait l'avoir amené à me voir johnny
sur son lieu de bande et champagne le
problème c'est que ça fait très mal à la
faire de sa vie une vie poudre la
boussole avait une panne moteur dans la
bouche et quand la bonne démarche dans
un bon soir
alors moi le truc le plus l élégance ray
j'ai pas l'ivresse de la pesanteur ou le
sait pas marcher sur la lune non savez
combien de personnes qui ont marché sur
la lune
bien sûr très bien 13 nombre d'experts
soit la trêve est la treizième away mais
rien n'a permis que trois ans vous direz
vous si je suis soit allumée il faut
s'entraîner comme un sportif faut voir
si on a tapé le regard toute la ligne
regardez qui veut venir sur un kit qui
reste sur la lune est une année
géraldine bach comme ça au kef thibault
qui n'y a rien à faire elle n'a pas de
sens du jeu peut-être vendre des marrons
chauds là bas
ça me extrait non mais vous aimez les
défis sportifs en plus il mentionné
comme un malade c'est vrai pour les
besoins d'une balle est pour gérer la
pesanteur la pression le vol et/ou ouais
ouais franchement at elle va bientôt
peut-être vous pourrez y avait pas plus
on peut on y vante déjà eu l'idée c'est
ça mais c'est quoi je pouvais pas passer
à tous et merci
vous avez envie d'aller sur la lune
avant oui je sais pas comment on voit ça
moi j'irai mais c'est une aubaine c'est
une équipe qui n'est pas prêt en
contrepartie ce qu'on peut faire c'est
écrit racheter son nom sur la fusée
d'accord prochaines prises et qui va
décoller vraiment votre nom ouais et on
vous envoie une photo de moubarak comme
quoi vous avez être sinon ouais là peut
être cool aussi
non j'en refais relais sur la lune je ne
sais pas il va alors toi qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire arrêter
de dormir à cause a plus on ouvre un bar
[Rires]
on devrait cartonner
ah ouais c'est grâce à un goal aux
arrêts ouais c'est doc quoi chez jack
welch et docks ouais ouais ouais
pourquoi tailleront tu crois vraiment je
vais quitter ici ça veut dire le gage
fin qui fit si brun voilà le public est
là au fait un kiff on rigole il croit ce
gars se trouve je vais tout quitter mon
frère pour aller avec celui-là en
thaïlande bondés des vodka orange ou
vert mais teinte arrête toi on va faire
un carton de fer au tout le monde va
là-bas vraiment envie d'y aller avec moi
ouais qui a dit vous allez y aller avec
lui et vous série ce serait quoi votre
votre truc le plus dingue vous
souhaiteriez faire way le plus dingue
que j'aimerais faire tout fait déjà
franchement je vais vous dire à moi ce
serait non moins chez moi c'est pas un
truc de fou mais j'aimerais j'ai un rêve
ouais j'aimerais pouvoir ne pas dormir
j'aimerais voilà déjà très bien non mais
j'ai envie d'essayer de ne pas dormir
pendant un mois endormir donc pendant un
mois l'a déjà fait à longueur de pages
de jamais dormir mais vous allez devenir
encore plus dingue
elle est venue pour amener pour des
compléments mais non ça rend fou 1-2 pas
là c'est vrai ça ouais ouais bah voilà
voilà voilà
à sept mois